leave your entries in the server any
crows the next episode of why welcome to
why the brand-new original show that
we're done episode 14 Wow time goes by
fast when you're having fun
isn't that right at least I haven't done
379 of these fourteen is that such a bad
number all too sudden
hope you enjoyed the original intro it's
made by day by day thank you very much
now let's go into the memes if you want
to submit your meme the Lincoln Center
description don't be shy I know you're
sitting on a really good mean for a
while now and you haven't submitted it
how are you gonna become anywhere in
life if you haven't submitted to the
reapply submission yet clearly you're
doing wrong things in life you haven't
gotten anywhere this could be your head
this could be your make it moment you
could submit a meme that would get
upvotes
on the pewdiepie subreddit do you
understand the opportunities that i am
presenting to you okay this is not me
taking content from you this is me
giving you opportunities you are welcome
I know I am a saint
I am the nicest guy ever nice guy
PewDiePie Christian Channel let's go
remember happy wheels this is it now
feel old yet original content original
game ideas be careful you call ugly in
middle school what do we got lost
oh very nice only true 30pi fans will
understand this meme okay only only
hardcore watch every single video
everyday twice two increases watch time
pewdiepie fans fam squads posted Anka's
memes you can find the broast squad fam
hold my beer scyatta
do
yeah this pretty much summarizes the
whole reddit good job everybody can't
tell if it's a good thing or if it's
Sasan did you have hey man it's a simple
question I still own I haven't gotten a
single person answering a second times
that you oh here we go again well Ben I
need to do another green screen soon let
me let me do that for next time
wait what the [ __ ] did you laughs or did
you lose I don't even get the meme it's
a lost meme you guys aren't ahead of me
I know hahaha I understand the meme haha
I get it EA oh I see it now well done
for EA I mean no there's no poori a
well-written structured original joke
loss it's kind of true I don't know why
it's funny don't think about it too much
it gets weird do you ever look at stuff
and wonder how he got there
it's been a tough year ok it's been it's
not been the best year for it 2017 okay
I didn't let's just say I don't want to
relive it
could this compete with Pierce chair
excuse me excuse me
this chair is much better perfect
holiday gift for you and your friends
who wore it better yeah that's it
that's a thick ass stranger yung lean
shirt and I will not have you
discriminate it for some sort of Disney
product thank you very much how would
you even get in and out of that huh
pathetic guys if I installed Windows 7
of 32 bits 2 times will it become 64
bits help please yes but it will host
windows 14 I don't think this was meant
to be this dark shoot the kids hang the
family free
Christian channel please what no one no
one shot shoot the kids hang the family
friend graduating from MIT watching all
seasons of Rick and Morty understanding
I had to take the video down and correct
myself because I was literally arguing a
get for net neutrality but accidentally
against at the same time it's a it's a
complicated a lot of people don't
understand it's the kind of you laugh or
did you laugh or did you lose kind of
thing and not a lot of people you need
to have a pretty much this level of IQ
perspective on pills what his parent
think he does what his viewer thinks he
does how to remove copyright claim 7% so
what Matt's here thinks he does respect
women what the media thinks as does this
is a very accurate so far what the
haters thinks he does P deep I Spit
that's actually true what he actually
just read off how to videos good job
everybody
rich female celebrities with hair like
this have a 125 per chance I'm telling
you how oppressed women are hey I don't
have that haircut anymore hey I'm not a
whamon I respect them that doesn't mean
but well this is just science again
that's true it's science its scientific
it must be hard it must be hard ok oh
wait did I just sell this damn it while
watching PewDiePie videos after a week
watching PewDiePie is videos every day
watching the video right after making it
public so you managed to watch the rich
yeah now now when I take a video down it
just cuts up everyone like before you
could finish the video even if I took
the video down YouTube 2017 everybody
not just me who pays the price now huh
but that when you make a subreddit and
your friends just use it to spend the
same
over and over again I made some mistake
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] be quiet be quiet please
Net Neutrality got repealed recently I
was pretty bummed out about it but I
think whoever repealed it but probably
more happy to see it go then I'm sad to
lose it no no you don't did he make this
did shenanigans make this this isn't
original that he was meme his own mean I
got layers boy that's impressive and
world hunger and world poverty suit kids
for cheating it was surprising how many
of you actually thought they were fine
to sue the kid apparently I made another
mistake they're the reason why he got
sued was because he counterclaimed the
video which the only option after that
is to take legal action so really epic
gains were just cornered oopsie I made a
mistake again
oopsy-daisy no one cares please keep
watching beautified filming if I never
seen this mean oh I never seen that one
that's really good never seen this meme
never ever have I seen this me please
keep posting it if you don't have a core
message that is making a positive impact
on the planet what the [ __ ] are you
doing that's right source shut ok I'm
making a positive impact I can't even
see edith's Coast West Coast
please guys please stop the Nazi memes
it's been eight months they're gonna
make another compilation okay they'll
make a anniversary edition I'm sure
please stop how to reach the ten minute
mark
quality content get the super sorry I
had to make a visit to the restroom I'm
sure my editor will just cut it out
[ __ ] you boots love though I stopped
slavery I stopped the Nazis
I stopped apartheid ice that was me why
do everyone keep being so salty at me
like oh it was your fault why are you
complaining about to monitize am i the
one that put the ads in the video oh
yeah no you're right I did I undercover
uploaded a bunch of okay I mean let's
get really with me now you know what
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you it's a Power Move by
the media because they canceled my TV
show okay they're like I have YouTube
this whatever way we tell them bunch of
losers let's keep striking okay if
YouTube kept my show they ad pocalypse
would never have happened YouTube is the
fault stop blaming me sexy hiking with
feet of fire that's awesome Killian
Wagner that's awesome thank you very
much that's so dope that's perfect for
like a phone background and we are
hitting the final page where the top
memes are all located this is the top a
percent of that 1% let's watch original
content Fridays with PewDiePie let's
play oh I see I'm jumping all over it
you're never gonna let it go huh me
while watching
I've never ever seen her do this what in
the world are respecters mean as a Swiss
tchen when you spend three hours
photoshopping a meme to get five uh
posts
yeah well you need to promote your memes
okay it's not just about you got a
network for the memes and this one made
it somehow so I don't know let's say if
you want to make it to the top you gotta
work for her alright the PD PI's
submission reddit is one of the finest
subreddits of all time it doesn't get
better than this it doesn't get better
when you're too broke to buy a game so
you just watch people play it on YouTube
this is a microaggression I think this
is a microaggression okay just because
you're an african-american gentleman
doesn't mean that you have any less
access to monetary gains new you laughs
you lose do you monetize Rio yes that
was good
well Beth you know what you get a you
get an b64 and review what the [ __ ]
please submit your means for the next
one don't forget to leave a like this is
a family-friendly Christian channel so
do tell all your kids to subscribe watch
the video three times and get it to
trending come on come on I haven't seen
a single one of my videos get to
trending in 84 years please squad fem
now